thanks to powerful telescopes
astronomers know what our universe looks
like today and they have a pretty good
idea of how it got started but what
happened in between how galaxies like
our Milky Way were created and how they
evolved isn't as clear
that's where simulations can help
scientists have now made one of the most
detailed simulations of the evolution of
the universe it spans almost 350 million
light years but includes enough detail
to zoom in on individual galaxies as
they grow the simulation starts 12
million years after the Big Bang this
view shows a chunk of the simulation
that is 30 million light years across
gravity is pulling dark matter into
dense pouches connected by wispy trails
that resemble a spider's web that's what
astronomers call the cosmic web in this
view the denser the dark matter of the
Pinker the color.this where stars and
galaxies are starting to form then
ordinary matter enters the picture we're
now looking at gases swirling in and
among galaxies which are growing bigger
and starting to collide cooler gases are
blue where stars form green gas is
warmer while red and white gases are
extremely hot and surround the most
violently active galaxies supermassive
black holes sit at the center of these
galaxies as the black holes pool in
matter around them they heat the
material and blow out gas in explosive
bursts of white
as time passes the explosions spread
warm gas throughout space
as the simulation progresses it also
shows how the elements such as hydrogen
helium carbon and oxygen spread
throughout space the diffusion of these
elements shown in purple is essential to
the development of stars planets and
even life approaching the universe as it
is today the simulation switches back to
dark matter it shows how the tightly
packed nuggets of dark matter in the
early universe have expanded over
billions of years to become the massive
galaxy clusters and superclusters such
as the Virgo supercluster we see today